qui criminalisent l'existence vagabonde.
Qui, ici, sait que dans de nombreuses villes
à travers les États-Unis, il est désormais illégal
de s'asseoir sur le trottoir,
de s'entourer d'une couverture,
de dormir dans votre propre voiture,
d'offrir de la nourriture à un étranger ?
Je connais ces lois parce que j'ai vu
des amis et d'autres voyageurs
qui étaient jetés en prison ou recevaient des convocations
pour avoir commis ces soi-disant crimes.
Beaucoup d'entre vous pourront se demander pourquoi
quelqu'un choisirait une vie comme ceci,
une vie sous le joug de lois discriminatoires,
à manger des déchets,
à dormir sous les ponts,
faire des boulots saisonniers ici ou là.
La réponse à de telles questions est aussi variée
que le sont les gens qui prennent la route,
mais les voyageurs répondent souvent par un seul mot :
la liberté.
Jusqu'à ce qu'on vive dans une société où chaque être humain
est assuré de sa dignité grâce à son travail
de façon à travailler pour vivre correctement,
et non pas uniquement travailler pour survivre,
il y en aura toujours
qui prendront la route comme un moyen de s'échapper,
de se libérer et bien sûr de se rebeller.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)